when it comes to like climate science I
don't think it's unreasonable to think
that humans could destroy the Earth's
atmosphere we easily could nuclear war
is one way to do it we could do a lot of
ways comets could destroy the Earth's
atmosphere but what's unreasonable is to
tell people they have to stop producing
waste and that's the way to solve it
like people are gonna poop we're gonna
make waste we're gonna burn stuff to
stay warm so we need to figure out a way
not to stop I I believe it's
unreasonable to expect people to stop
producing the carbon dioxide and we have
to be reasonable about the climate we
need to reuse the waste this is why I'm
obsessed with pulling the carbon dioxide
out of the air it'll create another
climate crisis where we start to pull
too much carbon dioxide out of the air
and then we start to compete with the
trees and we need like a United Global
Coalition that's working together to not
pull too much methane and carbon dioxide
out of the atmosphere because that is a
valuable resource